Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Quand on parle d’orientation sexuelle,
on pense souvent hétéro, homo ou bi
et c’est tout.
Pourtant, en plus des nuances qui
existent pour ces trois catégories,
on peut tout à fait
se retrouver en dehors.
C’est-à-dire qu’on peut
ne ressentir aucune attirance.
Jamais.
Ce que j’entends par attirance,
c’est cette attraction particulière
qu’on ressent envers une personne.
Il en existe différentes sortes.
L’attirance amicale, par exemple,
cette envie de venir
discuter avec une personne,
passer du temps avec sans aucun
sous-entendu amoureux ou sexuel.
Les attirances dont
je voudrais parler ici,
ce sont justement ces attirances
amoureuses ou romantiques
et l’attirance sexuelle.
Beaucoup de gens les confondent car
souvent on vit les deux simultanément.
On a envie de sortir avec une
personne et de coucher avec.
Sauf qu’en fait, ce sont
deux choses bien différentes.
Dans un plan cul, par exemple,
on peut ressentir seulement
de l’attirance sexuelle
n’avoir envie de rien
partager sauf le sexe.
À l’inverse, certaines personnes
voudraient pouvoir tout partager
sauf le sexe.
Cette absence d’attirance sexuelle,
dans ou hors des relations,
amoureuses ou quelles qu’elles soient,
c’est ce qu’on appelle asexualité.
En fonction de si on ressent de
l’attirance sexuelle et envers qui,
on peut donc être
hétérosexuel, homosexuel,
bisexuel ou asexuel.
On peut faire pareil avec l’attirance
romantique ou amoureuse,
cette envie d’avoir
une relation plus proche.
En fait, on peut avoir envie de relations
amicales ou bien physiques ou sexuelles
mais sans jamais
cette attirance romantique.
C’est ce qu’on appelle aromantisme.
En fonction de l’attirance amoureuse
qu’on ressent envers des personnes,
et envers qui,
on peut donc être hétéroromantique,
homoromantique,
biromantique ou aromantique.
Alors, c’est plus compliqué que ça
mais avant de revenir là-dessus,
je voudrais vous dire pourquoi
j’en parle aujourd’hui.
On peut se dire que ça ne
concerne pas grand-monde
et que ça relève de leur intimité.
Pourtant, d’après les quelques recherches
qui ont été menées pour l’instant,
les personnes asexuelles et aromantiques
seraient 1% de la population totale,
voire probablement plus.
En Suisse, ça fait 90 000 personnes.
Vous en connaissez forcément,
de près ou de loin,
que vous le sachiez ou pas.
Et puis, c’est vrai,
je suis aussi une personne
transgenre non-binaire.
Je ne me reconnais ni comme
femme ni comme homme.
Ça, je suis obligée de le dire
quasi quotidiennement
parce que ça change la façon
dont on s’adresse à moi.
Je préfère le neutre ou le masculin.
Je sais que lorsqu’on me voit,
on va penser plutôt madame.
Voilà, j’ai besoin de le dire.
Pour la sexualité et l’aromantisme,
c’est un peu différent.
Ça ne change pas la façon dont
on s'adresse à une personne.
Pourtant, nous avons
aussi besoin de le dire.
Parce que le reste du monde
semble nous dire non-stop
combien le couple et le sexe
sont au cœur de nos vies
dans les films, les livres,
dans les discussions.
« Et toi, toujours personne ?
Il faut que je te présente Machin.
Vous allez bien vous entendre. »
« Oui, c’est ça, vous êtes allé
faire un tour dans le jardin ?
Rien que  tous les deux ? »
C’est partout en fait.
Et quand on se sent en décalage
avec quelque chose
qui semble si fondamental
pour le reste du monde,
on risque de douter de ses ressentis
ou de mentir dessus pour
ne pas paraître trop bizarre.
Pire,
on peut se retrouver à se forcer dans
des relations qui ne nous conviennent pas.
Ou bien au contraire
à s’exclure totalement
en se disant que personne ne
sera jamais intéressé par nous
et qu’il vaut mieux être seul.
Plus concrètement,
le risque de suicide est avéré
chez les personnes asexuelles
et/ou aromantiques
comme l’un des plus grands
de la communauté LGBTQIA+.
Que vous soyez concerné ou pas,
en parler,
dire que nous existons,
expliquer ce que l’on vit,
c’est permettre à d’autres de
se reconnaître et de se respecter ;
à leur entourage et
à la société en général,
de mieux nous comprendre
et de nous faire une place.
Moi,
j’ai toujours eu de l’attirance amoureuse,
aussi loin que je me souvienne.
Je ne suis pas du tout aromantique.
Par contre, la dimension sexuelle
ne venait pas avec.
J’avais bien écouté
mes cours d’éducation sexuelle.
Je me disais que ça viendrait
pour moi aussi, un jour.
Et puis, le temps passait
et le décalage grandissait.
Alors, vers l’âge de quinze ans,
je me suis dit :
« Bon, apparemment, le sexe,
ça ne m’intéresse pas
mais ce n’est pas grave.
Si une personne m’aime vraiment,
on s’arrangera, tout se passera bien. »
À 18 ans, j’ai eu ma première
relation amoureuse
et ça ne s’est pas exactement
passé comme ça.
Il m’a fallu une semaine
pour lui en parler
et je lui ai proposé
d’aller voir ailleurs si besoin.
Sa réponse, c’était :
« Mais moi, je n’ai pas envie avec
n’importe qui, j’ai envie avec toi. »
Attirance sexuelle.
Moi, je croyais vraiment que c’était
plus ou moins un loisir comme un autre
et qu’on avait envie de le faire avec
des personnes qu’on aime de préférence.
On a fixé la barre plus
ou moins à mi-chemin
entre son désir et l’absence du mien.
Je ne vous conseille
vraiment pas de faire ça.
Même avec tout l’amour
qu’on avait ensemble,
de son côté, c’était frustrant
d’essayer de m’écouter
remettre tout en question.
De mon côté, très honnêtement,
il m’a fallu des années
pour m’en remettre,
me pardonner de m’être forcé,
d’avoir cherché des limites
plus loin que les miennes
alors qu’au fond, je savais.
Heureusement, quelques mois
après le début de notre relation,
j’ai découvert le mot
magique « asexualité ».
J’existais, je n’étais pas le seul,
je n’étais pas malade,
pas cassé, pas anormal.
À partir de là, j’ai appris
à mieux me comprendre
et à m’affirmer dans
mon absence d’attirance sexuelle.
On a avancé comme ça tous les deux.
Mais d’autres choses marchaient
moins bien et on s’est séparé.
Le problème s'est posé plus tard
avec d'autres personnes.
J’ai eu aussi des relations
pleines d’amour et de tendresse
où le sexe avait été mis de côté
puisque je n’avais pas de désir.
Pour revenir au concept,
j’aimerais partager
trois points importants
sur lesquels on se trompe souvent.
Une personne asexuelle et/ou aromantique
peut avoir,
numéro un,
de l’attirance pour certaines
formes de relation et d’intimité,
vivre des relations épanouissantes,
qu’elles soient amicales ou physiques,
à notre façon, vraiment.
Deux.
On peut ressentir du plaisir sexuel,
de l’excitation physique et de la libido.
C’est juste plutôt physiologique.
Pas du tout orienté envers une personne.
Ça peut arriver à tout le monde,
même sans désirer une relation sexuelle
à un moment donné
avec une certaine personne,
on peut tout à fait ressentir
cette excitation physique
et ce plaisir lors
d’une stimulation sexuelle,
quelle qu’elle soit, seul ou pas.
Et pour rappel, ce n’est pas
parce que le corps a l’air d’accord
que la personne est consentante.
Seul un oui est un oui.
Et numéro trois.
On peut choisir d’avoir ou pas
des relations amoureuses ou sexuelles,
même lorsqu’on ne les désire pas.
De nouveau, ça vaut pour tout le monde.
Il y a plein d’autres raisons que
le désir qui peuvent nous y mener.
On peut vouloir faire
plaisir à une personne
ou bien se faire plaisir
à soi-même physiquement.
Ou encore essayer
quelque chose de nouveau.
Concevoir un enfant.
C’est à la personne de décider
en connaissance de cause,
mais son choix est respectable,
quel qu’il soit,
en fonction de son désir ou pas.
Et toutes les combinaisons sont possibles.
Ça dépend juste des gens.
La dernière notion que je voudrais amener,
c’est celle du spectre.
Il est faux de penser qu’on a ou pas
un certain type d’attirance.
On pourrait plutôt dessiner
une échelle de grandeur,
avec ici, les personnes qui
ont souvent de l’attirance,
ici, celles qui n’en n’ont
que rarement ou jamais.
C’est ici que se trouve
le spectre asexuel et aromantique.
Chez ces personnes qui n’ont pas ou peu
d’attirance sexuelle et/ou romantique.
Les personnes demisexuelles
ou demiromantiques, par exemple,
peuvent ressentir l’une de ces attirances
mais seulement dans certains contextes.
Moi, je suis biromantique,
je peux ressentir de l’attirance pour
des personnes, quel que soit leur genre.
Par contre, en temps normal, je n’ai pas
d’attirance sexuelle dans ces relations.
Pourtant, après trois ans
avec une personne en relation amoureuse,
j’ai commencé à ressentir
cette attirance sexuelle.
C'était tout à fait inattendu.
Ça n’a pas révolutionné notre relation.
C’était juste là.
Je n'avais jamais ressenti ça avant.
Ni pour elle, ni pour quiconque d’autre,
quel que soit son genre
ou l’intensité de notre relation.
C’était un contexte particulier
qui a fait naître
cette attirance particulière.
Je suis demisexuel mais très
proche d’une asexualité totale.
Quand on parle d’orientation
sexuelle ou amoureuse,
on pense hétéro, homo, bi
ou asexuel et/ou aromantique.
Ces orientations ne se choisissent pas
et ne se guérissent pas.
Aujourd’hui, même si on est loin des 1%,
les représentations sont de plus en plus
nombreuses, complexes et réalistes.
Si vous vous posez des questions
pour vous, pour une connaissance
ou juste par curiosité,
il n’est jamais trop tard pour
se renseigner et pour en parler.
Et quoi qu'il en soit, n'oublions pas
que chaque personne est unique.
Communiquons, écoutons-nous,
questionnons-nous,
et réjouissons-nous de nos diversités.
(Applaudissements)